but first we start with breaking news
learning the death of a teenager at a
party in North Las Vegas Police telling
us the 14 year old died in his shooting
happened last night at the Craig Ranch
Village off Commerce right near Lone
Mountain that is where 8 news now
reporter Madison Kimbrough joining us
live with what she has learned about
this case Madison
residents who live at the Craig Ranch
Villas are Satin by the news that a
child is now dead but unfortunately
they're not surprised that a shooting
took place here North Las Vegas Police
confirming that it was a 14 year old boy
who was shot just before 9 30. neighbors
say that within the last couple months
it's been nothing but chaos here with
the police showing up on a weekly basis
a neighbor who wasn't comfortable
showing her face on camera recalls what
she heard last night
as far as I know they were having some
sort of party around the corner here I
believe it was a graduation party and
next thing you know gunfire going off
and car speeding out of here and then I
guess there were some teenage girls that
were walking by and they um were
screaming and hollering I can't believe
they did that
as for the identity of the child the
coroner's office has yet to release that
info it's still unclear if the boy died
on scene or was taken to a nearby
hospital a North Las Vegas Police have
yet to confirm who they may be searching
for and if that person responsible is
now in custody reporting live in North
Las Vegas Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now